hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round two of the 2020
Tata Steel a chess tournament it's
Wesley so versus Vishwanathan Anand and
it seems like there's something in the
Tata Steel tournament that makes on and
plays a spectacular chess if you
remember in 2013
Allen 3d here's the mortal game in the
tata steel masters edition against LaVon
our neon with the black pieces if you
haven't seen that game I will put a link
to it in the description below it will
be the first thing thing you will see so
do check it out if you haven't really an
outstanding game but here it's also just
attack attack attack as the quote above
the board says so without further ado
let's check it out really really awesome
stuff so waster with the white pieces
opens with E for now we have a 5 9 f3
Knight to c6 sorry about that
and we have Bishop to c4 the Italian is
on the board we have Bishop to c5 and
here be for the Evans gambit was not
played in this game but it is a it is an
excellent choice choice for white in
this position we have c3 the main line
of the Joko piano by Wesley and Mountain
Knight to f6 we have D 3 d6 and Knight B
to d2
Anand castles the safety with h3 taking
away the g4 Square from blacks pieces
and the now a6 preparing b5 so here you
could push a for Wesley prefers
Bishop to b3 he wants to tuck away the
bishop to c2 to help out with the
defense of his center Bishop to e6
offering a trade of dark square bishop
and here Wesley just goes back Bishop
the c2 and now as Wesley's Bishop no
longer fights for the center and takes
this opportunity to play d5 so d5 and
here Knights the g5 and it's interesting
it's a move 10 between two elite
grandmasters but this game was already
played in 1988 between two unrated
players or maybe they were rated
something like 1600 but very very
interesting stuff in their game Queen to
d7 was played and the white was able to
win the game fairly easily but he Ronon
goes for D captures on e4 we have Knight
captures any six
a nice in-between move F captures an e6
and now D captures an e for you cannot
go Knight captures on e4 because then
after Knight captures you cannot
recapture due to the attack on f2 so
Wesley goes for D characters on e4 and
this is where the the magic happens here
Anand goes the Bishop captures on f2 so
a nice Bishop sacrifice as if the King
recaptures and the King will recapture
you go in front of the rook and then all
sorts of nasty discoveries become
possible so here Wesley captures and now
comes Knight to g4 check if you go for
Knight captures any for chapter 2 grab a
pawn while we're at it it's not all that
weird because after King to g1 you don't
really have any any good ideas if Knight
f2 I thinking you're gonna win back some
material White has Queen to h5
threatening bursts of to h7 widow would
have made in mating maneuver and here
you don't have any good choice if he for
dangerous Bishop captures still with
with the same threat so you're gonna
have to trade to captures captures and
there's not much much black can do here
or after this Queen to h5 move you can
play g6 but then just okay Queenie to
Knight capture screen captures and White
has two pieces for the rook and it's not
like black has the attack or anything
here you're just gonna go but Knight f3
are gonna go to page 6 you're gonna
bring the rook into the game and slowly
but surely win the game so after King
captures and I have to Wesley goes
Knight to g4 with a double check now
after the King moves nice to e3 is
coming with a double attack on the Queen
and under Bishop the Queen will be
unable to keep an eye on the bishop so
King g1 and the Knights to e3 now so the
Queen has to move with quinta e 2 and
now comes the Knight captures and c2 so
it seems like it's not the bishop
sacrifice wasn't actually sacrificed
because you win the piece back by force
however the knight has no squares to
escape so the knight will be lost so
here look to be one of course you're not
allowing that and now point is if you
continue Queen d6 you prepare some rook
f6 rook a af8 just knight of three and
the next move white will pick up the
night the night has no escape squares so
after will be one
continues in great style night six the
d4 with an attack on the Queen so what
do you do here well Wesley captures it
with C captures and now Queen captures
with check also possible it just
captures a capture Sun before where you
will have a nice pasture deep on but
Anand prefers Queen captures on d4 with
check with rook to f2 and rook f28 f8 so
really a lot of stuff happening kink the
h2 and the now rook to f2 and already
you have to be very careful you don't
have all that many squares with the
Queen you have like Queen D 1 you have
Queens you four and Queen to h5 those
are the squares that are available to
although not a lot of them are good for
example if Queen d1 just to recapture
some G to check King captures 93 check
pics of the Queen a lot of a lot of
ideas like that hanging in the air so
Queen to g4 is best because you keep an
eye on the G to point and also
threatening Queens the e6 with check
here Anand continues with nice to e3 it
comes with an attack on the Queen also
you're threatening rook captures and G -
Wesley grabs with check if he didn't
have this check it would be game over
so Queen captures would check King h8
and now you have to guard the G to point
so rook to g1 and now you basically have
to decide between bringing the rook into
the game although rook 8 f8 doesn't
really come with a come with any threat
so and also you don't want to allow
something like Knight b3 with an attack
on the Queen because if the knight is
captured and it's just all over White
will be able to develop and well white
is of material so first island goes
Queen to d3
it prevents any piece Wesley has from
developing the knight now cannot move
because the rook would hang if the
knight doesn't move the bishop doesn't
come into the game and well everything
is just nicely paralyzed with with this
Queen to d3 move okay Wesley takes what
he can Queen captures on e5 and now
Anand has to decide what to do here now
if you if you run this position on the
engine the engine will give you night
captures and g2 and although this is the
strongest move this is one of those
positions where playing the strongest
move simply isn't enough our point being
that
after rookie actress Angie - if the rook
is captured then you have rook capture
screen captures and the now Quinta e -
with check and now you have a you have a
draw by professional if the King goes
back you're just checking now Queen e1
Queenie to check and if you the King
goes out the board you're gonna go rock
f8 and now it's already becoming
dangerous for white so not something you
want to do but all in all it should end
in a draw however after Knight captures
ng - Wesley doesn't have to capture the
night Wesley can just go kink - h1 and
now the night is paralyzed you cannot
move the knight because of Queen g7 mate
so here you have to go into Queen
captures on h3 check Queen h2 captures
captures and then now you have
discoveries but not very good ones 93
check let's say King h3 and the game
continues where Wesley is still up a
piece but Anand is up two points so of
course white white is to be preferred
here so these are the two options so by
going Knight captures on g2 at best
Anand will be down a piece and up two
points so now like I said one of those
cases were playing the best move
recommended by the engine simply isn't
enough so Anand first prepares it rook 8
f8 now Knight captures and g2 really is
a threat for example if Wesley makes a
slow move it's a three and now Knight
captures here is very dangerous you
still cannot capture the night but if
you go King h1 now it is different Queen
captures on h3 check queer Queen h2
captures and h2 captures and now Knight
to f4 with check and now with the rook
and f8 it's a problem now because if you
go here then just night e to check picks
up the rook and if you go kink the h1
then rook f6a wins followed by rook to
h6
so rook a to f8 creating a lot of
threats for for the white king so Wesley
goes back Queen g3 adds another defender
to the g2 pawn and now again what do you
do here and if you capture now point is
if you capture now not Queen capture
screen because then you have a discovery
I discovered check from the rook pics of
the Queen so here we would just have a
trade route captures and g2 rook
captures and g2 Queen captures and g2
and that's that's about it white is just
up too much material and you don't have
any
good ideas if queen III threatening rook
F - it's not a problem Knight c4 opens
up the attack on the Queen Queen moves
and now Bishop to h6 White will give up
some material this is all forced so
that's why I'm showing it this way
threatening made in Europe a piece so
completely winning so here after Queen
to g3 by Wesley Allen goes Queen to d2
he adds yet another attacker here and
also threatens to bring rook f6 to g6
the 4th attacker to the G to pawn so
this is an incredibly difficult position
to solve and there is only one good move
for Wesley so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this only winning
move for Wesley while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
it's it's well one of the tougher moves
I've asked you to find in a long time so
for those of you who found it too really
congratulations
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's before the move we
said didn't happen at the start of the
game now it happens and this is the move
that wins the game point of the move is
now rook f6 oh and this rook f6 the
story rook f6 the g6 idea is met with
rook the B 3 and now route g6 just you
can capture on e3 there there are no
more threats and if and if rook captures
on g3 you grab the Queen just the rook
captures any - you grab the Queen as
well
rook captures on h3 yes you will grab
upon but rook captures here and the
White has the white is up to pieces so
of course completely winning so this is
why the b4 move is so strong because of
rook to b3 and then you you are able to
unwind
so here Anand that went for the only
thing he had left if you go Knight
captures and g2 again there's the
problem of king h1 and you run out of
moves
then I cannot move because of checkmate
and now it's black who has problems
so he run and went for the only thing he
had left rook captures and G to rook
captures and g2 and now Knight captures
and g2
so of course the knight cannot be
captured because of rook F to winning
the Queen so after Knight captures Angie
- Wesley played Queen to g4 and it was
in this position
- wanna turn and resigned the game and
well a remarkable game played by both
players a brilliant attack followed by
brilliant defense and Indians
Wesley prevailed what if you resign well
of course you cannot rate Queens if you
trade Queens then well you just move the
knight and you're down a piece so not
really something possible
and another thing after Queen to g4 you
could try moving the Queen point being
that if okay if Queen captures you still
have rook to have to trapping the Queen
but then just rugby three attacks the
Queen Queen moves you still hope for
Queen captures but just better be - you
offer the night for a nice checkmate
here and if rook g8 just look to g3 and
now it's over
Black has no more defense whatever you
do Queen captures now it's just a nice
forced mate captures captures and
captures so after Queen to g4 Anand
resigned and a an awesome victory for
Wesley so in round 2 of the twenty20
Tata Steel masters edition so we're not
gonna be showing the standing says this
is only round 2 and I might show a game
or two from from round 2 so we're gonna
wait with the standings a bit maybe
after round 3 I would like to thank
Gustavo Candia Carlos Montero
Dorian Matata which Pete Ronix and who
saw covenant for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you in
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel the Women's World Chess
Championship match and we have started
editing the subscribers video so stay
tuned for that so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day